[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
good
morning class of 2025
transfer students
eli whitney students and visiting
international students welcome to yale
i am marvin chan dean of yale college
and joining me on this platform before
you are the officers of the university
the heads and deans of the residential
colleges
the deans and staff members of the yale
college dean's office and athletics
we are so pleased to be with you today
in person
family members and friends who are
joining us remotely we extend our warm
welcome to you and we thank you for
everything you have done
in guiding these young adults
congratulations on this proud and happy
moment
class of
[Applause]
class of 2025
in the entire 320 year history of yale
college
you are the greatest entering class ever
[Applause]
in number
with
1815 of you joining as new students this
year
and for the first time in at least half
a century we are hosting opening
assembly on cross campus
this is a place
that you will come to know well
because you will be spending so much
time here
in sterling memorial library uh behind
us
and in bath library below us
surrounding this group are three of the
14 best residential colleges in the
world
behind you on your left grace hopper
college
[Music]
at your front left trumbull college
[Music]
[Applause]
and flanking the platform berkeley
college
[Applause]
where my wife uh professor wu young anne
and i raised our two children uh when i
served as the head for nine years i
literally lived right there on the on
your right
and also to your front left there is the
women's table designed by alumna maya
lin celebrating what is now 152 years of
co-education at yale and 52 years of
co-education in yale college
to your far right a block away yes
co-education
to your far right a short block away
the is a magnificent schwarzman center a
newly expanded hub for student life
our campus more grand than ever is
embedded within the city of new haven
also more vibrant than ever
and within what is now the state of
connecticut yale acknowledges that
indigenous peoples and nations including
mohegan mashentuck at pequot eastern
pequot scotticock golden hill pogoset
niantic and the quinnipiac and other
algonquin speaking peoples have
stewarded through generations these
lands and waterways
we honor and respect the enduring
relationship that exists between these
peoples and nations and this land
in my role as dean i have the privilege
of supporting president salovey's
mission
for yale to be the research university
most committed to teaching and learning
what that means is that i am here to
make sure that you get the best liberal
arts education and extracurricular life
that yale has to offer in the classroom
and outside of it
a good part of what you will learn here
will come from the faculty who will
teach you in the classes you take
while much will come from your peers and
colleagues around you
taken together these teachers of yours
will give you the liberal education that
is yells hallmark
and by the time you graduate you will
have furnished your mind in the broadest
possible sense not by pursuing narrow
specialized study but instead by
searching for new knowledge
new perspectives new ways of looking at
the world and by adding your own
if you make good use of this place you
will discover fields of knowledge that
are completely new to you
and that you have never heard of and you
will open yourselves to them and learn
from them
to help you get as much as you can out
of your four years here you will get
plenty of advice along the way
and here are some of my own to get you
started
before you even start thinking about
academics or world domination start with
the basics
take care of yourselves and not just
your own self but the people in your
lives
start by listening to what your parents
and guardians have been telling you all
along get enough rest and sleep eat
healthy exercise and spend time with
your friends
in the excitement of the discover
discovery awaiting you it's easy to
forget this good advice so remember it
in the months and years ahead
and there's more beyond these basics and
it's just as important
if you want to flourish here
this past summer the olympic games were
held in japan
and one of the biggest international
stars was american gymnast simone biles
she is arguably the greatest gymnast of
all time
she has won 32 olympic and world
championship medals including four gold
medals in the 2016 olympics
she can perform routines of
unprecedented difficulty
and basically she can fly
with her performance at its peak and
expectations higher than ever it seemed
like a foregone conclusion that she
would take home every gold medal in
women's gymnastics
but she started off poorly
and then pulled out for most of her
events because of the twisties
a disability that caused her to lose her
awareness of her balance and body
position
both critical to performing complex
gymnastic routines
pushing forward risks serious injury
and so to front page headlines simone
abruptly withdrew from most of the
competition
her choice did prevent her from becoming
injured
but it did more than that
it also gave her teammates the chance to
compete and to gain both individual and
team medals themselves
simply put she showed how taking care of
yourself
can also be a way of helping others
some people say that winners should
never quit
that they should always grind forward
sacrificing everything even their health
and safety
according to this philosophy
withdrawing is a sign of weakness
i disagree
i am a neuroscientist
and i do not distinguish between the
mind and the body
i see performance
brain fitness and mental health
as interdependent
i applauded simone's choice
so did many professionals who saw her
withdrawal as a sign of strength
she had the maturity and confidence to
step back to avoid injury to herself and
to avoid putting her teammates at a
disadvantage
simone did not suck him to outside
pressures to gain more medals
she did not need them to feel valued and
respected
and whether she knew it or not
performance research shows
that people achieve their best when they
are not trying too hard but instead
striking the right balance of exerting
themselves and relaxing
you need both
and so i ask that you learn from
simone's champion mindset
every single one of you has earned your
spot to be at yale
the olympics of higher education
you do not have to count on any test
assignment or grade
to prove your worth
what's important now is to enjoy the
process of learning and being in
community with each other
you will feel stressed at times yell
will surely challenge you
but it's important to pace your efforts
and sometimes that means stepping back
taking a deep breath
and accepting help
and you will find people everywhere who
can provide it
faculty members heads deans and
directors advisors counselors coaches
chaplains yell health yale college
community care clinicians and wellness
specialists and your friends and family
members
but also remember
this most of the time
others cannot remove the
pressures that you feel
you need to do it for yourself
caring for yourself
and caring for others will help you
learn from each other and that is a
lesson that will enrich your time here
yale brings together the most
interesting students from all around the
world
so that you can all teach each other new
ways of understanding
you have all earned a place in this
community because of the promise you
have shown and what you will contribute
to it
when you get to know your friends
joining you this year
you will find that you come from every
possible walk of life
bringing with you every imaginable
talent every experience every world view
learn how to draw on your different
backgrounds views talents and interests
and how to see the world through each
other's eyes
here's a quick demonstration
it's one that shows a fundamental
principle of psychology of how we all
experience the world differently
your program
has an inserted side
the one with a graphic
take a look at it now
look at the top image of the insert
and you'll see an ambiguous figure that
can be seen in at least two different
ways
uh name out loud what you see
thank you
so some of you saw a duck
some of you saw a rabbit
and of course if you step back you can
try to see it another way the other way
that you didn't see it at first
can you see it both ways
okay good if you can't see it both ways
um we can talk to your dean
so the way this works uh to help you
along uh the ducks bill
you know pointing up to the top left
forms the rabbit ears and the rabbit's
nose facing right
is the back of the duck's head
now look at the cartoon on the bottom of
the page
there are two armies facing each other
each army is brandishing a flag that has
the same ambiguous duck figure duck
rabbit figure on it
and you'll see on the bottom a general
stands in front of the army
and he is urging his troops with the
following caption that i will read out
the caption for this cartoon is
and this is again the general speaking
on the bottom uh trying to rally his
troops he's saying
there can be no peace
until they do not renounce their rabbit
god and accept our duck god
so the new yorker uh cartoon
uh you know and so the the message here
is how can we help everyone understand
that they are serving the same flag
our perceptual interpretations our
memories and our thoughts are all
constructs of the mind
and they differ across people even when
considering the same object
event or evidence
yale will expose you to views different
from your own and when it does you can
start by finding common ground
with people when you don't agree with
them
as yalies
as our newest members of bulldog nation
you are all under one flag
and with the sophomores juniors and
seniors the alumni faculty and staff and
with each other you have common ground
an immediate shared bond that goes deep
to the intellectual curiosity and the
commitment to community that you have
brought here that have brought you all
here
you have just arrived at a place that
values difference
and actively seeks it out
it is how professors and students find
and test knowledge
and it is how the university equips its
students that's you
to become leaders and citizens of the
world
but here the value of seeking difference
is even more than that
here it is taken as an article of faith
it is the coin of the realm it is one of
the bedrock principles that governs us
in and out of the classroom
let me assume that you have come here
not only to find knowledge but also to
learn how to live lives of consequence
if that is true you have come to the
right place
as you take your first steps
then you will need to become comfortable
with difference
not just to accept it or tolerate it but
to insist on it
you will find guides everywhere in the
classes you will take
the activities you join and most of all
from the people joining you right now
your peers and classmates
all of them are part of the liberal arts
education that awaits you
your life at yale has started as it and
as it does here's what i hope you will
do
keep an open mind defer judgment
cultivate your patience and show grace
if you are a duck person go find those
rabbit people and find common ground
with them
if you are studying all duck horses
go find the rabbit courses
and see what they can teach you
and when you find yourself rallying
around a duck flag
take a good hard look at that rabbit
flag across the field and the people
rallying around it and remember that you
are all yelis
members of the class of 2025 transfer
students eli whitney students visiting
international students
you belong to yale
and yale belongs to you welcome
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
may we
always be searching for
[Music]
as peace
[Music]
open thyroid
[Music]
may we
always be searching for
truth us
[Music]
all
around let there be lights
[Music]
may we
always be searching for truth and
[Applause]
good morning everyone
to all eli whitney students
transfer students
visiting international students
and first year yale college students
welcome to yale
[Applause]
let me begin by saying it is good really
good to see you here today
and many families and loved ones are
watching today's ceremonies online
and on behalf of my colleagues here on
stage and the entire yale community
i want to extend a warm greeting
to everyone joining us
wherever you are
right now
this is a big moment
for you
our newest
students and for yale
i'm so glad you're here
51 years ago
university president kingman brewster
delivered an address to the entering
class
of new undergraduates
welcoming them to yale
just as i'm doing now
at the time the university was coming
out of a very unusual year
we can relate
just a few months earlier in may 1970
tens of thousands of people from across
the country
had come to new haven
and to yale
to protest the trials of bobby seale and
erica huggins
leaders of the black panther party
who were being tried
for murder
thousands of national guard troops
had been deployed to the city
as some expected the protests
to turn violent
the situation was extremely tense
fortunately reason prevailed
the protests remained largely peaceful
and no one was seriously injured
let alone killed
still
these events rocked yells campus
war was raging in southeast asia
movements for civil rights and women's
rights were heading in new directions
and across society
it seemed like a younger generation
was rising up to challenge
the old guard
against this backdrop
many people were wondering
about yale's future
they were uncertain about the
university's role its purpose
in a rapidly changing
and unpredictable society
standing here today i'm feeling many of
the same emotions that president
brewster must have felt
in 1970
looking out
over that gathering of new students
he knew many of them were anxious
he knew they had questions
about what they would do at yale
and many more about the kind of society
they would encounter
when they graduated
yet
in his speech
he was asking them
to study
to go to the library
to write papers
to conduct experiments
was asking them
to be students
and so he gave voice to a question that
was probably on the minds of many
a question
i also pose to you today
he asked and these are his words
where then
is the purpose
which which makes patient learning
supportable
when the world is on fire
where then is the purpose which makes
patient learning supportable
when the world is on fire
today
again
it seems like the world is on fire
literally
and metaphorically
the united states is in the midst of his
greatest crisis since 9 11.
we are fighting a global pandemic
which will be for many of us the most
significant geopolitical and perhaps
personal event
of our lives
but that is not all
this summer we have witnessed terrible
wildfires drought
and flooding in many corners of the
globe
some of you have experienced these
climate disasters
firsthand
not only climate change
but also racism
extremism
the widening gulf between the rich and
poor
these are complex challenges
that call out for urgent
and concerted action
the world is on fire and again we asked
what is our purpose here
and how do we learn
patiently
seriously
and rigorously
as i sincerely hope you will in times
such as these
and thinking about the answer to this
question
i was reminded of moussar sometimes
called musser in english
a 19th century
jewish movement
that came out of lithuania
very close to where my ancestors
were rabbis
the central idea of the mussar movement
and of similar religious and ethical
practices beyond judaism
is that we must improve ourselves
before looking outward at society
seeking to change it
we must examine our values
expand our knowledge
and develop our empathy
and imagination
one of the rabbis of the time is said to
have told this story
i set out to try to change the world
but i failed
so i decided to scale back my efforts
and only tried to influence the jewish
community of poland
but i failed there too
so i targeted the community in my
hometown of rotten
but achieved no greater success
then i gave all my efforts to changing
my own family
and failed at that as well
finally i decided
to change myself
and that's
how i had such an impact
on the world
much like this sage we are here to make
an impact on our communities and on the
world
don't get me wrong
but first we must start
by improving ourselves
your college years are a time to develop
your strengths and talents to challenge
yourself in ways you did not think
possible
to gain knowledge and understanding
and to explore
here at yale you will encounter new
ideas and engage with people from
different backgrounds
and walks of life
you will take intellectual risks
and ask questions about everything from
the structure of the cosmos
to the structure
of a novel
improving yourself
means leaving your comfort zone
signing up for classes that sound
interesting
but unfamiliar
going to office hours with slightly
intimidating professors
you may be surprised by the common say
conversation
that unfolds
attending talks by speakers whose views
are different than yours
and really listening
to their arguments
regardless of what you study or the
clubs you join
i promise you
that you will not leave yale
the same person
you are today
you will be changed
transformed by yell
we know that you are ready for these
challenges
and we are excited to see
what contributions you will make to yale
how you will write new chapters in our
shared history in the coming days
weeks
and years
thinking back
to that spring of 1970
i'm reminded of four yale college
students who with others
played a pivotal role
in the may day events
kurt schmoke
ralph dawson
bill farley
glenn de chabert
they were serious students
and active
and active in founding and leading
the black student alliance
at yale
two would be named rhodes scholars
that spring along with kingman brewster
his special assistant sam chauncey
and other administrators
these students showed exemplary
leadership
during a time of crisis
they were in some
instrumental
in helping keep the peace on campus
and most likely
saving lives
the world was on fire
but their time at yale prepared them
to tackle important challenges
then
and after graduation
one as a big city mayor and university
president
others as distinguished attorneys all
as engaged community members
like generations of alumni
these yellies were deeply committed to
making themselves better
making the university better
and making the world
better
you too
are joining the yale community
at a historic moment
we're surrounded all sides by fires
small
and large
and yet i could think of no better
moment
to be at
yale we begin this academic year with a
renewed commitment
to nurture this community
and the people in it
yellies
you will soon discover
love to learn
they seek out new experiences
and they immerse themselves fully
in everything
they do
at yale you can study with top public
health experts who are advising
governments on the pandemic response
you can take a seminar with a pulitzer
prize-winning historian of frederick
douglass or a leading authority
on john milton
you can conduct research alongside
faculty members
in over 1200 laboratories
yells great strength
now as always
is that we learn from
and are inspired
by one another
although we come from different places
we share a common purpose
and that is to improve ourselves
so that we can improve
the world
yale's mission statement expresses our
highest ambitions it says in part yale
is committed
to improving the world today
and for future
generations
it goes on to say yale educates aspiring
leaders worldwide
who serve all sectors of society
you
you
are those aspiring leaders
and this mission is our answer
to the question my predecessor asked
over 50 years ago
i believe
the patient learning president brewster
spoke of
means deep engagement in your studies
it means challenging your thoughts and
beliefs
it means expanding the frontiers of
knowledge
your own
and then the worlds
it means using your time at yale
to prepare for the trials ahead
in this sense
patient learning
is not only supportable
but essential if we are to fulfill
yale's mission
and indeed
improve the world
i will end with lyrics written by one of
my favorite folk singers
woody guthrie
in his song worlds on fire
his words are only too applicable
while the skies they're clearing
we'll rise up dreaming
build our city
from the ashes
yes
the world is on fire
but right in front of me
i see
many reasons for optimism
together
as part of this community
you will dream
you will
build and you
will prepare
for lives
of leadership
and service
welcome
to yale
[Applause]
time
passes
quickly
[Music]
fading
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
breathe
and close your eyes
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
you
must
[Music]
r
[Music]
the song rings out
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my
please
my beloved yale family
as we ready ourselves to step out onto
new ground
in this daunting yet inspiring liminal
space
of the unknown next
we begin a poignant turn of goodbyes and
hellos
that invite laughter tears
challenge choice discovery and pride
let us go forth with deep trust in
certain knowledge
that in this place
each and every one of us is welcome
that in this place
we will both stumble
and soar
that in this place
love surrounds us
beauty can surprise us
in this place light and truth awaits us
on this day and every day forward
may all that is holy shine upon us
and tenderly bless
our every breath
may we go
in shalom
in salam
in shanti
may we go in peace
let us begin
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you